hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
over at our patreon oh my god
Greg saying this again we do TV show
reaction watch along for many a shows
and weekly Q&A s and John does music
video coverage then yeah that's one of
our top reward tiers whatever video your
question was definitely doing put up on
the youtubes there I said it we plugged
it alright and today comes from Gregory
Bullock and he's asked us to do a
WatchMojo video that has nothing to do
with movies so maybe this isn't as
diverse top 5 CIA secrets that were
Declassified not if you guys know this a
huge fan of the CIA love it fall or
Twitter love what they do with all that
intelligence yeah man
surveilling people and spying on stuff
some people might say that the clia the
central lack of intelligence agency not
seen central intelligence I have I'm
just messing with you man I've totally
seen that thing you're referring to but
I'm not gonna say what it is in case the
audience doesn't know cuz I don't want
to you know spoil their chance to guess
it and feel like they're smart too I'm
gonna hit play act ok there's Meet the
Fockers
every day so be sure to subscribe to our
channel and ring the bell to get
notified about our latest videos don't
for this learning it I love how bad
[Music]
so examples like Operation Northwoods
which was a scheme conceived by the
Department of Defense with the
government's Joint Chiefs of Staff in
which they wanted the CIA and other
operatives to commit terrorist attacks
in US cities are excluded ok one of the
most important things that a Nazi
Germany should undertake ok World War
two ended many of his former top minds
fled while others faced the Nuremberg
trials however this period also gave
birth to Operation Paperclip which was
run by the Joint Intelligence Agency and
CIA precursor office of the Strategic
Services until the CIA itself was formed
in 1947 the secret program was an
America's mission to source the best
Nazi geniuses and offer them asylum
ignoring their crimes in exchange for
working for the US these included burner
phone who developed the infamous v2
rockets for Germany he later created
technology that helped America win the
space race and put a man Oh awesome
like animal cruelty however unbeknownst
to the public the CIA was doing their
own animal experiments at the same time
really inside the ear of a cat in order
to record sensitive russian
conversations it took seven years to
develop the technology and train a cat
which is no mean feat as well as
surgically implanted
and wires and a cost of between 10 and
20 million dollars unfortunately the
first test cat was reportedly hit by a
car number three the kidnapping of the
Lunik the fact that the Soviet Union
took the initial lead in the space race
called the US when Russia set their
spacecraft Luna on a tour of several
countries the CIA took advantage of this
finding a weak link in the security
chain they managed to borrow the
spacecraft as it was being transported
working and precisely they managed to
take it apart in order to photograph the
ship in precise detail Wow watch it put
the ship back together overnight awesome
51 military base in the entire world and
yet the US government didn't officially
acknowledge its existence until 2013
many claim that alien spaceships are
stored here but the truth behind area 51
isn't as spooky as the x-files would
haven't believed it's a damn where
America builds its high-tech top-secret
aircraft for example we miss you too
small planes were first developed
secretly there in the 50s and 60s it
seems that all the UFO sightings are
actually sightings of experimental
aircraft unless of course that's exactly
what they want us to think and they
really are hiding evidence yes
Topsy I would prefer to believe that
there's no such thing
sausage no Honorable Mention soldiers
and citizens led to the CIA
conducting their own experiments into
mind-control North Americans were given
LSD and other drugs in an effort to
brainwash them and that's just one of
the things MKULTRA was studying hypnosis
electroshock treatment and potential new
truth drugs were also used all without
informed consent from their victims the
director of the CIA ordered all files on
MKULTRA to be destroyed to this day
nobody knows the true extent of what the
CIA may have done do you agree with our
dicks check out these other I mean I
know so many more CIA stuff hahaha but I
think you guys nailed it down to the
worst part would you leave HAARP off the
list
guys totally got it I hope the comments
are filled with conspiracy theorists
just being like oh you forgot this idiot
you don't anything I guess the most
disappointing one would have to be the
area 51
I'm just billing aircrafts we're gonna
get the whole like alien thing from
that's where I'm curious I mean I guess
that makes sense to me in the sense that
if we're testing out experimental
aircraft and somebody sees that they'll
be like I've never seen that flying
thing before and maybe that's how this
all happened but at the same time it is
a bummer just to be like oh we're just
building planes alright damn yeah but
not to be something with aliens though
there has to be what's the thing is it's
a class refused to believe there's not
they've Declassified it but it's like
none of us have been invited onto the
grounds just to poke around so any
number of extraterrestrial life-forms
that's true
or maybe there's an area 52 somewhere we
don't know about well I can't talk about
that's classified yeah of course the
first one Operation Paperclip sounds
like it'd be a good movie yeah I'm also
just surprised at all that we classified
that we were just like hey guys just FYI
we took a bunch of the most de
workers for the Nazi regime and we give
them jobs but we needed to get to the
moon first John we can't yeah
we can't let them Russians yeah we can't
make it to the moon first our pride is
is really the most important thing if
there's one thing I learned from first
man is they oughta beat those Russians
you got to beat the rush job and have to
that's the most important part of life
I mean why I honestly can't tell you but
I do know what it's not amazing to get
to the moon unless you're America unless
you're America if you're if you're not
first you're last Ricky Bobby
we can't work together it's not possible
we don't do that so I say bring all the
Nazis as long as we were first yeah sure
why not
there there there there there there
there there there there there superior
intellects can rot in the prison cells
man you know paying for the various
atrocities they ate it in I recently
watched the biopic Overlord oh yeah and
seeing what they were we were on the
verge of having near indestructible
humans those horrible American soldiers
completely halting the progress of
science exactly so if we had worked with
the Nazis dad you know think of where
the world would be think of how much
better Trump will be as a present oh he
would have the utmost support if he were
the Nazis you know it's like gosh
Trump gotta get ya man suppress the Free
Press to do whatever you want make up as
many facts yeah it's great this moment
the cat I don't know if you saw that
face here I was really loving that that
is awesome
I'm a cat lover matter of fact the day
we're shooting this I posted a photo
with myself and my lady's cat called
Watson I love cats so to hear what they
were doing in these cats first reaction
was that is horrible that is awful
let me first have done is they put a
microphone in the ear of a Nazi
scientist
yeah why don't you start there yeah to
do it's an animal's mass I mean you
can't even control the cat what do you
know it's a freaking cat if the cat legs
runs off it goes yeah I can like jump
out a window it is long I'm leaving out
of this stupid you know I know you can
train cats to a certain degree but I'm
sitting here thinking how are you gonna
train any cat to the point that you'd
need them to like infiltrate yeah how
are you gonna place this cat on the
exact person you need and then a
guarantee that they're just around yeah
shadowy conversations or I mean that's
horrible
I gotta admit one part of me made me go
I would love to do that to my
girlfriend's cancer see the [ __ ] she
does when I'm not around who did she
talk to on the phone when I'm not there
I mean it's not a very this technology
available I'd like a maxtor DIY wire up
your cat that was the thing I was
actually curious about was the physical
implications of X I'm like okay you put
a mic in their ear but how you're
talking about batteries and wires cat's
ears that may not be good for a cat yeah
like was this horribly painful like yeah
that's what I mean that's why it sounded
awful to me cuz I'm like that just that
was probably just so unhelpful have
those like radio waves and [ __ ] right
there blah you know it's like nowadays
maybe we could make it more palatable
but back then I'm like this technology
wasn't that small and that unobtrusive
to where you're not yeah just gonna be
radiating those cat's head weighing it
down with machinery I never saw it in
figures it's hidden figures based off
this it may figure in somewhere well
dude if we have to steal from the
Russians in order to beat the Russians
yes
USA all the way is my motto number five
yeah I mean I don't think this is as bad
as some of them but I do think it's like
weird Lisa slices broke one yeah this
would make a pretty fun little heist
movie yeah
yeah we're gonna steal this cabbage
we'll take it apart photograph all the
pieces and put it back together a little
like that's so wacky as compared to
these other things that seem either
atrocious or misty well do you know
listen we have to be the Russian we have
to it's important okay this one though I
was way into this project MKULTRA with a
mind control yeah this is infant always
wanted to know how to mind-control
someone that's something I would legit
Google had a mind control and I just
wish that they did not can this project
I mean sir their methods did not seem to
be the best way of approaching the
matter but I really emphasize the but
there we need to know how to do it
because you know there's like bad guys
and stuff not so I could you know like
convince my girlfriend to have a
threesome or something we just need your
chair again terrorists or if we need new
Netflix shows minion Network shows or if
I'm trying to you know steal someone by
making them give me their wallet but
that's not why I'm thinking about I'm
talking about you know someone's been
kidnapped I mean you know where they're
located that's where I'm coming from
from the heart is there you know I'm
just in it for the LSD really half the
people abducted to do this study
probably got like a pretty cool
experience and the other half got a
really horribly traumatic experience
that destroyed their lives in their
bodies I'm a pineapple Express is making
fun of that's a beginning I think to a
degree they're touching on it anyway
what emotions do you feel they destroyed
the files apparently but there's a lot
you can read about MKULTRA it's
fascinatingly horrific I don't know man
I feel like we should bring it back I'm
sure that there's if we can get to 400
patrons I'm going to take all the money
on our patreon page and donate it to a
separate GoFundMe page so we can get
project MKULTRA back up and running
project MKULTRA - wouldn't that be a
good movie project MKULTRA - we were
like hansung the first one
like it's not about watching the first
one this is about you know you'll get
yeah it's different young adults trying
to escape from the test facility and we
can use the muse song as the theme song
to the movie it's gonna be perfect this
is why we are called the real rejects
because rebel injected by a studio near
you I like shadowy government secrets
even if they've been Declassified yeah
man they're horrible but they're fun to
muse about but one thing is true if the
President does it then it's okay that's
okay
yeah that's not the president doesn't it
is okay everybody used to do it today
well thanks Gregory Bullock hope you're
doing well buddy appreciate you always
checking in recently you asked me to
keep you in your prayers and you have
been so I just want you to know that
we're always here for you always have to
try to make you smile that's why we were
just making nothing but very sincere
comments throughout this whole video oh
I just want to make you smile with
sincerity and not sarcasm because you're
a good-hearted guy seriously go look he
is Bullock Bullock American dad that is
the name that Patrick Stewart plays of
the head of the CIA Bullock it all ties
in and if you ever release a punk album
you can call it never mind the bollocks
you know what like the classic Green Day
album by the punk band Green Day who
invented plenty day I'm just waiting for
the comments and tell me I'm an idiot
alright guys would your favorite
government conspiracy explain it to us
in devastating detail below subscribe to
the real rejects click the bells no no
ring the bell that's what's happening
and check us on patreon we got stuff